well kirsten as you can imagine it's
been a long day for residents here near
charleston and hualapai is you can see
portions of spanish steppe's lane has
been blocked off by metro police and as
you heard just minutes ago from vanessa
more patrol officers
just arrived here to the scene pushing
back all the media first it was about
half a block and now we're about a block
away from his home and of course all of
this unfolding as neighbors are still
shocked this high profile case is all
happening across the street
really wild you know you wake up in the
morning and you see the police tape
attached to your tree in your front yard
devin bonadue is new to the tuscany
trails neighborhood he was definitely
concerned today a weird combination
lately so seeing something like that is
not something you see normally it's
something you hear like a true crime
series or like a movie so you know to
think it actually might have happened
isn't wild early wednesday morning metro
police served a search warrant at clark
county public administrator rob telus
home on spanish stepp's lane days after
investigative reporter jeff gearman was
killed it's none of my business
islamists doesn't affect me i'm not
committing crime i don't care i assume
they were serving a warrant of some sort
and just would worry how the person
would react
you never know who your neighbors are
around noon investigators towed the suv
parked outside of telus home similar to
a picture police released of a vehicle
on tuesday sources tell 8 news now telus
was with the investigators for several
hours until coming home where 8 news now
investigator vanessa murphy questioned
him did you do this tell us anything if
it comes out being true what they think
that'd be really wild i mean you know a
politician and not not exactly hearing
the best things from
another reporter so it's crazy
well back out here live as you can see
police again
creating a very heavy presence here
around this area all of this as tell us
is currently inside his home in that
grey house
about a block away from where we're
standing now neighbors say he was very
involved in the neighborhood events and
we do want to clarify telus is not
charged with a crime and asked for
employment with the county amid this
investigation we have not received a
definite response christian casadas 8
news now